[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير اهلا بكم الى
نشره الرابعه من الرياض التي نقدم من
خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات السعوديه والخليج
هذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
بعد نحو اسبوعين من الزلزال انتشار ثلاثه
ناجين من تحت انقاضها ووفاه احدهم لاحقا
فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي يواصل
عملياته في 46 موقعا بثلاث مدن تركيه
امنوا حلف الناتو يقول بانه من الواجب
توسيع العضويه في حلف الناتو لتعزيز الامن
في اوروبا
ومن ملفاتنا في الرابعه كذلك
تقرير للانتربول بان جرائم الاحتيال
المالي تشكل تهديدا خطيرا لدول الشرق
الاوسط
الداخليه السعوديه تعلن ترحيل اكثر من 12
الف مخالف لانظمه الاقامه والعمل خلال
اسبوع
حياكم الله نبدا الرابعه من تركيا حيث
رافقت كاميرا العربيه عمليه انقاذ ثلاثه
اشخاص بينهم طفل من تحت الانقاض في
انطاكيا بمحافظتها طاي التركيه عمليه
الانقاذ جرت بعد قرابه 300 ساعه على
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا فجر
السادس من فبراير الماضي ولاحقا توفي احد
الناجين وهو طفل
يتحدثون الفرق لانقاذ الان تخبرني بان
وجود تم انتشار ثلاثه اشخاص على قيد
الحياه والعمليات ما تزال مستمره هنا في
هذا الموقع كما تتابع هنا ايضا تم انتشار
جثتين من هذا المكان
تم انتشال هاتين الجثتين من هذا المكان في
وسط هاتاي
وكما اخبرنا فريق الانقاذ من قرستان تم
انتشار ثلاثه اشخاص اثنين بحاله جيده وشخص
وطفل في حاله صحيه
سيئه نتمنى له الشفاء العاجل
ومن هاتاي جنوب تركيا ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه زيدان زنكلو زيدان مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في الرابعه
لازلت امام ذات المبنى الذي انتشرت فرق
الانقاذ منه ثلاثه ناجين
وبينهم الطفل الذي توفي بعد خروجه الى اين
وصلت عمليات البحث والانقاذ في الموقع
الذي انت فيه الان
نعم نايف عمليات البحث والانقاذ في هذا
المبنى الذي نشاهده الان ما زالت مستمره
من قبل فريق
فريق انقاذ من قرغيزيستان انضم اليه ايضا
الفريق انقاذ محلي في محاوله للوصول الى
اشخاص ناجين اخرين عمليات البحث ما زالت
مستمره احضروا العديد من الاجهزه لقياس
الصوت
وموجات الصوتيه تحت الانقاض على ما يبدو
ان هناك معطيات لديهم بوجود اشخاص ما
زالوا عالقين تحت الانقاض لذلك طلبوا من
الجميع لمرتين خلال الساعات الماضيه الصمت
والجلوس على الارض واطفاء الهواتف
المحموله حتى اطفاء محركات السيارات ومن
ثم لمرتين متباعدتين في كل مره تقريبا
لا اريد المقاطعه لكن هذه الصوره الان
لاحد الاشخاص ربما يستخدم اجهزه معينه
يعني قياس ربما كما ذكرت
الاصوات او الاجسام ايضا الحراريه تحت هذه
الانقاب
نعم هذا الشخص الذي تشاهدونه هو على
الشاشه
في الجرافه هو من الجيش التركي فريق مختص
من الجيش التركي وصل قبل حوالي ساعه من
الان الى الموقع للمشاركه في عمليات البحث
كما ذكرت يعني هناك معطيات على ما يبدو
لدى فرق الانقاذ بوجود اشخاص ما زالوا تحت
الانقاض لذلك العمليات تكثفت خلال الساعات
الماضيه بعد انتشار ثلاثه اشخاص كانوا على
قيد الحياه اب وام عائله سوريه مكونه من
اب
وام وطفل بعمر 12 عاما مع الاسف الطفل
فارق الحياه بعد انتشاله بدقائق حاولت فرق
الانقاذ هنا انعاشه وتقديم
او محاولات انقاذ كانت حديثه للطفل لكن
فارق الحياه ايضا تم انتشال جثتين لاطفال
اثنين تعتقد فرق الانقاذ انهما اطفال
العائله ذاتها طبعا الاب والام تم نقلهم
الى مشفى ميدان قريب ومن ثم تم نقل الام
في مروحيه الى اضنه احد مشافي ولايه اضنه
القريبه لتلقي العلاج هناك يعني عندما تم
اخراجهم كانوا في حاله جيده بعد 296 ساعه
قضوها تحت الانقاض انقاض هذا المبنى
المكون من خمسه طوابق بحسب ما علمنا من
سكان هذا الحي في وسط مدينه انطاكيا
بالعموم يعني اذكر في هذه المعلومه ان
الجهود الانقاذ مستمره في 300 موقع
في اربع ولايات غالبيه هذه المواقع تتركز
هنا في هاتاي وفي كهرمان مرعش وايضا بدرجه
اقل في اديمن وموقع وحيد في ديار بكر هذه
هي الحصيله حصيله مواقع التي ما زالت فرق
البحث وانقاذ تواصل العمل بها قبل قليل ان
تذكرت ان احد الناجين نقل بمروحيه الى
مستشفى
خارج هاتاي وذكرت ايضا معلومه المستشفى
الميداني اريد ان اسال عن الطاقه
الاستيعابيه في في هاتاي تحديدا انطاكيا
كيف هي هل النظام الصحي يواجه صعوبه في
معالجه المصابين او ربما ايضا حتى فيما
يتعلق بامور
الاشخاص الذين قضوا تحت الانقاض من عمليات
الدفن ربما ايضا وغيرها كيف يمكن رصد هذا
الوضع لان انا اليوم نتحدث عن 12 يوما بعد
الزلزال
نعم نعم نعم نايف لا شك ان هناك عديد
المشافي الميدانيه التي تم استحداثها هنا
في هاتاي
لمحاوله
التعاطي مع اعداد الضحايا واعداد المصابين
الكبيره ما يتم او ما تستطيع الطواقم
الطبيه هنا التعامل معه والحالات التي
يمكن ان تتعامل معها يتم التعامل معها هنا
في هاتاي دون الحاجه الى نقلها الى مشاف
اخرى لكن في حال كان هناك حالات مستعجله
كما في حاله السيده السوريه التي تم
انتشالها اليوم يتم نقلها بشكل عاجل اذا
كان الوضع يتطلب حتى النقل بواسطه الطيران
يتم نقلهم جوا كما ايضا في حاله السيده
السوريه التي تم نقلها بمروحيه مباشره الى
اضنه ايضا في حال كان هناك اكتظاظ في
مشافي اضنه يتم نقل المصابين الى وحدات
العنايه المركزه ايضا جوا في مشافي انقره
وفي اسطنبول لذلك يعني يتم التعاطي مع هذا
الموضوع الحالات التي يمكن التعاطي معها
او التعامل معها في موقع الحدث يتم
التعاطي او التعامل معها من قبل الطواقم
الطبيه اما في المشافي الرئيسيه في هذه
الولايات او في المشافي الميدانيه
المستحدثه بعد الزلزال وفي حال كان هناك
حالات صعبه وحرجه يتم نقلها جوا الى
ولايات اخرى انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل
هذه المعلومات والصوره التي نقلتها لنا من
هاتاي في انطاكيا جنوب تركيا مراسل
العربيه زيدان كلو شكرا لك
نبقى في ذات الملف حيث اظهرت مقاطع فيديو
حجم الذماري والاضرار الذي لحق بمدينه
جنديرس السوريه بعد الزلزال المدمر
[موسيقى]
هذا هو يواصل فريق البحث والانقاذ السعودي
اعماله لمساعده المتضررين في زلزال تركيا
لليوم التاسع في 46 موقعا في ثلاث مدن حيث
اسهم في انتشال العديد من الضحايا
[موسيقى]
ماساه السوريين مستمره ان جون منهم في
ادلب وجدوا ملاذا امنا في مخيم مؤقت حيث
فضلوا البقاء فيه عوضا عن البيوت المتصدعه
والتي قد تنهار في اي وقت جراء الهزات
الارتداديه هل اعلن بها المخيم ما في شيء
ما بنعرف وين نروح
نستاجر خيفاني عم يصير هزات كتير يعني
مبارك صارت كلها زهوره
على جيراننا ونحن بيتنا كل الصداع كلياته
طلعنا من
خوفنا نخاف كتير من هالرجال الارتداديه
جينا مشان بيتنا
وبيتنا طابق سابع اولادي عم بخافوا اقعد
جينا لهون الله يجزيهم الخير اعطونا خير
وبركه
يعني خوفا على الاطفال
الحمد لله رب العالمين
وقت صارت الهزه طلعنا يعني من تحت الانقاذ
نحن عيال من طلعوا من تحت الرديم
جينا لهون باركنا ما ضل عنا شي طاول
لاغراض لا لبس لا شيء
تحت الركاب تحت
يكون مخيم لا يكون يعني طلع بركينا على
البحر
يعني بدنا خزانات بعازه كتير شغلات هون
بالمخيم ف
جاه قريه كبيره
هذه الخيم لا تحوي بنيه تحتيه لتصريف
الماء ولا لحمايه
الموجودين في الخيم من
الصقيع الموجود هون يعني امبارح كان
الصبره هيك سماكته تقريبا يعني ناقص خمسه
تحت الصفر
فقدوا اباهم وشقيقتهم الصغرى ونجت شقيقتهم
الكبرى باعجوبه من تحت الانقاض هي قصه
اطفال وعائله سوريه لاجئه في تركيا فقدت
اغلى ما تملك في الزلزال نتابع تفاصيل
القصه مع مراسلنا زيدان
لاجئون السوريون في تركيا عادوا مجددا الى
الخيمه بعدما دمر الزلزال منزلهم بقي
الاطفال دون والدهم الذي توفي مع شقيقتهم
تحت الانقاض وهم يعيشون الان في خيمه عمهم
بمدينه اصلاحيه في غاز عنتاب فكرت من
زلزال مثل اي يعني هزه ارضيه عادي وقتلي
يعني نايم الصغير هذا على يمينه والمرحومه
على يساره
شلت الصغير وطلعت فيه لبرا لقيت ولادي
هدول الاثنين قمر ومحمد قدامي بره طلعت
ابوهم الله يرحمه
ورانا فورا هدم البيت ما يعزي هذه العائله
هو نجاه سمر اكبر اخوتها بعدما بقيت تحت
الانقاض ليوم واحد انا كنت نايمه على
الكنباي فلما صار الزلزال وقعت من
الكنبايه على الارض وما له خبر انه البيت
كلياته
كان عم بيصيحه ابويا
بس انا كنت فكرت انه هو معي بنفس الغرفه
ضليت عم اصيح له ما كان يرد علي لان صوته
يعني كان قاعد هو بالصالون
فصارى يصيحوا برا اتراكم السوريين قام انا
وهنا رديت عليهم لما اعرف انه انا كنت
موجوده تحت البيت صار يقولوا انه في صوت
تحت البيت
شقيق الاب يؤكد انه لم يستطع انتشار جثه
اخيه في بدايه الامر ورغم طلبه للمساعده
لكن انتشال الجثه تم بعد ثلاثه ايام
من بيته لبيتهم
طلعتك من بعيد شفت ايده ايده
غير اصابع وايده يعني
بنته تحت
المنهج محسن نطلع نصبه نزله على راسه
والله ما عارفينها
بعدين صرنا نطلب مساعده ما في حدا اجا
ساعدنا ضل ثلاثه ايام واليوم الرابع لحتى
توفي الاب وابنته وترك بقيه الاطفال
ايتاما كحال الاف الاطفال الذين فقدوا
ذويهم رحل عمود البيت وهو مصطلح يطلقه
السوريون على رب الاسره وما اكثر الاسر
التي بقيت دون معيل زيدان زنجلو العربيه
من مدينه اصلاحيه غازي عنتاب
قال كبير الدبلوماسيين في الخارجيه
الصينيه وانجلي اثناء مشاركته في مؤتمر
ميونخ للامن قال ان العالم يراقب ازمه من
طاد بين بكين و واشنطن عن كتب واضاف كبير
الدبلوماسيين في الخارجيه الصينيه ان نظره
الولايات المتحده تجاه بكين نظره خاطئه
جدا وقال وانجلي ان واشنطن تصرفت مع
المنطاد بانانيه وانتهكت الاعراف الدوليه
باسقاطه كما تحدث كبير الدبلوماسيين في
الخارجيه الصينيه عن الحرب في اوكرانيا
وقال ان بكين ليست جزءا من الازمه في
اوكرانيا لكنها في الوقت ذاته لن تبقى
مكتوفه الايدي وشدد وانجلي على اهميه عدم
خوض اي حرب نوويه تحت اي ظرف
قالت وزيره خارجيه الالمانيه انا لينا
بيربوك خلال كلمه الله في مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن قالت ان محادثات الاتفاق النووي مع
ايران وصلت الى طريق مسدود وشددت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه على ضروره منع اي
تصعيد نووي من ايران
في المانيا ومن مؤتمر ميونخ للام تستمر
لليوم الثاني توالي تظاهرات مجاهد خلق
الذين طالبوا خلال الاحتجاجات باضافه
الحرس الثوري الايراني على لائحه الارهاب
الاوروبيه
[موسيقى]
شدد رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيوسك على
الحاجه الى النظر في تعزيز الدفاعات
الاوكرانيه على المدى البعيد جاء ذلك خلال
لقاء جمعه بالمستشار الالماني
مؤتمر ميونخ للامن وقال سوناك ان على
الحلفاء التفكير فيما هو ابعد ومن تحقيق
السلام في المدى القريب
حضرها الامين والعملي حلف الشمال الاطلسي
ينسى سولتنبيرج على ان ما يحدث في اوروبا
اليوم يمكن ان يحدث في اسيا غدا مؤكدا ان
الصين تراقب الوضع عن كتب
اعتماد اوروبا على الغاز الروسي اضعف
موقفها الامني وما يحدث اليوم في اوروبا
يمكن ان يحدث في اسيا غدا فالصين تراقب
الوضع عن كثب لهذا يجب ان نضاعف دعمنا
لاوكرانيا لان بوتين يحضر لمزيد من
الهجمات ويتواصل مع ايران وكوريا الشماليه
للحصول على الاسلحه ومن دون حلف النيتو لا
يوجد امن في اوروبا ولهذا يجب العمل على
توسيع العضويه في حلف الناتو وارسال
المزيد من الاسلحه لاوكرانيا والتي قد
ينتج عنها الكثير من المخاطر لكن في
النهايه لن نسمح لبوتين بتحقيق النصر
ومن نيويورك تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
راغده مساء الخير مرحبا بك معي في نشره
الرابعه من الرياض يعني ربما منذ الصباح
والجلسات تتوالى المسؤولون يتحدثون عن
عديد الازمات في العالم هذه الساعه ربما
ساعه استراحه للمشاركين في مؤتمر ميونخ ما
الملفت تصريحاتهم هذا اليوم والذي يمكن
القول بانه رسم الخط العريض لمؤتمر ميونخ
للامن هذا العام
اهلا بك يعني سمعنا تكرارا من كل الزعماء
الغربيين الذين تداولوا على الحديث منذ
اليوم الاول لهذا المؤتمر يوم امس بانه
يجب ان يستمر الدعم لاوكرانيا مهما طالت
هذه الحرب ويجب ان لا نسمح للرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتين بان يفوز في هذه الحرب
لانها تؤثر على يعني كل العالم وليس فقط
على اوكرانيا نفسها بل على اوروبا وعلى
العالم اجمع واليوم امين عام النيتو قال
بانه هناك دول تراقب هو يشير الى الصين
تراقب ما يحصل هناك وربما يعني تستعد لي
كانت تاخذ خطوات شبيهه باخذ اراض بالقوه
كان ملفت جدا اليوم كلام المسؤول الصيني
الوحيد الممثل في هذا المؤتمر وربما هو
المسؤول الوحيد الذي كان اصلا من خط غير
خط الزعماء الذين يعني تداولوا على الحديث
والمشاركين هنا لانه هذا العام روسيا
مستثنيه من الحضور وايضا ايران لذلك
الطرفين اللذين الدول الاورو او الغربيه
هي على خلاف معهما غباء عن هذا المؤتمر
وبقيت الصين التي وجه المسؤول الصيني
الموجود هنا الموجود هنا انتقادات لاذعه
خلال كلمته للولايات المتحده وصف تصرفها
فيما يتعلق بازمه المنطاد بانه تصرفه
هستيري يعني استخدم كلمات بالفعل يعني
يمكن اعتبارها حتى خارج اللغه الدبلوماسيه
المعتاده وايضا يعني هذا الامر الان يطرح
علامات استفهام حول امكانيه لقائه بوزير
الخارجيه الامريكي انت الذي يعني لم يؤكد
هو اصلا ولا الخارجيه الامريكيه اللقاء
ولكن كان هناك امل بان يلتقي الرجلان
ويناقشه عن قرب مساله هذا المنطاد والتوتر
بين الطرفين لذلك ربما هذا كان الموضوع
الطاغن ولكن كان هناك ايضا موضوع ايران من
دون شك طاغم اليوم بشكل كبير خاصه وانه
كانت هناك جلسه في الصباح شارك فيها
ناشطون ايرانيون ونائبه من حزب الخضره
الالماني في البرلمان الاوروبي الى نائب
في الكونجرس الامريكي
ويعني يعني كلاهما المسؤولان الغربيان
تحدث او النائبان الغربيان تحدثا عن ضروره
زياده الدعم للمحتجين وحتى النائب
الاوروبيه قالت انه لن نرتاح من مخاوف ان
تكون هناك ايران نوويه الا بتغيير النظام
ولكن يعني هي لم تقل بان الدول الاوروبيه
او الغربيه يجب ان تتدخل لاحدى ذلك ولكن
قالت بانه يجب ان ندعم المحتجين لكي يعني
يحققوا اهدافهم والناشطون المتبقون
الايرانيون قالوا بانه احد اهدافهم بطبيعه
الحال هو تغيير هذا النظام الايراني
القائم الان فيما يخص ايضا الملف الايراني
على مستوى الاحتجاجات على مستوى النووي
وغيره يعني هناك كذلك نشاط اخر يخص ايران
لكنه خارج هذه القاعده نتحدث عن ربما
تنظيم لبعض التظاهرات لمجاهدي خلق وهي
المعارضه الايرانيه ما الذي رصدتيه
حتى الان راغده
افعل كان هناك تجمع اليوم ايضا
ص في الوقت نفسه التي كانت
تجري فيها الجلسه التي تناقش ايران يوم
امس كانت هناك ايضا تطورا شبيهه لهم
وتدهور اخرى منفصله لمؤيدي عوده الملكيه
الى ايران في الواقع انه هذه التظاهرات
يعني رغم انه الجميع التطورات الايرانيه
هنا والناشطين يؤيدون مبدا بانه يجب يجب
مواجهه النظام الايراني وتوقف والوقف عن
تقديم الدعم له ولكن هناك خلافات ظاهره
بين المعارضين الايرانيين لانه الذين
شاركوا في جلسه اليوم كانوا ينتقدون
مجاهدين خلق يقولون بانهم لا يمثلون
الايرانيين في الداخل والمجاهدين يقولون
بانه رضا بهلوي الذي دعي للحديث في مؤتمر
ميونخوه لا يجب دعوته لانه يعني يذكر
الايرانيين بتاريخ ماض يعني بماض سيء وبما
حدث يعني ايام الثوره عندما تمت الاطاحه
به لذلك يعني كانت هناك دعوات صدرت من
المشاركين الغربيين النواب الغربيين في في
جلسه ايران تدعو الايرانيه للتوحد
ونبي توحدهم هم يكونون اقوى يمكنهم يعني
بالتالي مواجهه النظام الايراني بشكل يعني
اكثر فعاليه ربما ولكن كما ذكرت الاهداف
التي يعني جميعهم ينادون بها هي يعني هي
اهداف مشتركه بانه يجب دعم المحتاجين اكثر
من مجرد كلمات ويجب ايضا يعني
عزل النظام الايراني شكرا جزيلا لك من
ميونخ انضمت الينا مراسله العربيه
الرابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل
عدن وصوله 45 الف طن مترين من الديزل ضمن
المنحه النفطيه السعوديه
حياكم الله من جديد خلال كلمه القاها في
مؤتمر ميونخ للامن الدولي قال رئيس المجلس
الرئاسي اليمني رشاد العلي قال ان بلاده
ترفض املاءات المشاريع الايرانيه على
الشعب اليمني اضاف العليمي ان هدف حكومته
يكمن في رفع المعاناه عن الشعب والنبلاده
تشيد بكل الجهود او ترشيد بكل الجهود التي
تقدمها السعوديه لبناء سلام دائم في
المنطقه
وصلت الى محافظه عدن في اليمن دفعه
الثالثه من منحه المشتقات النفطيه
السعوديه الجديده بكميات بلغت 45 الف طن
متري من ماده الديزل و30 الف طن من مترين
من ماده المازوت وتاتي منحه المشتقات
النفطيه الجديده امتدادا للمنح السابقه
باجمالي باربعه فاصله اثنين مليار دولار
امريكي ضمن استجابه السعوديه لطلب الحكومه
اليمنيه مساعدتها في توفير المشتقات
النفطيه لتشغيل اكثر من 70 محطه لتوليد
الكهرباء في انحاء اليمن
كشف تقرير للانتربول حول اتجاهات الجريمه
في العالم لعام 2022
وكشف بان الجرائم الماليه وجرائم الاحتيال
المالي تعد واحده من بين خمسه مجالات
اجراميه واسعه في العالم تقرير الانتربول
اكد ان التسارع معدلات الرقمنه خلال ازمه
كورونا زاد من معدلات انتحال الهويات بغرض
الاحتيال المالي حول دول الشرق الاوسط فقد
افادت تقرير بان الاحتيال المالي يعد ضمن
اكثر التهديدات الخطيره والخطيره للغايه
امام تلك الدول
وفي العاصمه السعوديه الرياض تنطلق غدا
الاحد فعاليه ورشه عمل حول الجرائم
الماليه عبر الانترنت بتنظيم من جامعه
نايف للعلوم الامنيه وبمشاركه خبراء عرب
ودوليين في مجال مكافحه الجريمه الماليه
عبر الانترنت
وستناقش الورشه التي ستستمر لثلاثه ايام
محاور منها اساليب الهندسه الاجتماعيه عبر
الانترنت الاكثر شيوعا في الاحتيال المالي
بالاضافه الى حالات واقعيه لتلك الجرائم
وافضل ممارسات للتحقيق فيها
وينضم الينا هنا في الاستوديو مدير مركز
الجرائم السيبرانيه والادله الرقميه
بجامعه نايف العربيه للعلوم الامنيه
الدكتور عبد الرزاق المرجان الدكتور عبد
الرزاق حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من
الرياض اهلا وسهلا خليني ابدا معك من هذا
التقرير المهم للانتربول واللي وصف فيه
دول الشرق الاوسط بان مستوى الاحتيال
المالي فيها هو خطير وخطير للغايه لماذا
اولا مستوى الاحتيال المالي فيها بهذا كذا
خطوره طبعا اول شيء اشكرك طبعا الخطوط
تكمن في رقم واحد ارتباط الجرائم الماليه
بالانترنت اصبح الانترنت لاعب رئيسي ومسهل
لعمليه الاحتيال المالي لذلك الارتباط هذا
وضع ادوات معينه
للجرائم المجرمين او المحتالين عبر
الانترنت واصبح الضحايا اكبر شريحه كبيره
جدا على مستوى العالم يستطيع ان يتعامل
معها ويستطيع ان يستغلها ويقوم بجمع
الاموال هذه خلقت بالنسبه للمحتالين انهم
يستطيعون اخفاء تتبعهم لن يكون تتبعهم
بالطريقه المشروعه او انك تستطيع ببساطه
تتبع الاحتيالات الماليه او ضبط المشبوهين
كذلك الاسلوب الاجرامي في استرداد الجرائم
استرداد الاموال من خارج الدول اصبح من
الصعب جدا فاصبح صعب جدا ان انا اصبحت
الان تجاره كبيره جدا استجاره سوداء وذكر
تقرير في الامم الاوروبي اتحاد الاوروبي
ان مجموع التجاره الغير مشروعه من
الاحتيال المالي 110 مليار يورو لم يسترد
منها الا واحد في المئه انت تتكلم على
الاتحاد
اقل من مليون واحد في المئه لك ان تستطيع
فانت تتكلم عن تجاره ضخمه دخلت فيها
التقنيه كما ذكرت لك بامور كثيره كذلك
الضعف او القله الوعي في في عندك عندك
كذلك في المستهدفين اضافه الى استقلال
المحتالين للاجراءات لان لابد ان نعرف ان
الاحتيال المالي يتجه الى اتجاهين اتجاه
يكون الضحيه هو جزء من هذه العمليه مشارك
او الجزء الثاني الضحيه لا يكون له ولكن
تم استقلال الاجراءات بحكم خلينا نتكلم
على قله الراعي الدكتور عبد الرزاق انا
عارف ان عندك كلام كثير يعني تريد الحديث
بحكم عملكم اليومي طبعا في هذا الموضوع
لكن اتوقف عند نقطه قله الوعي عند عند
الضحيه
هل هي اولا سبب رئيسي ام ان التشريعات
ربما او القوانين او حتى حمايه هذا الضحيه
ليست بالقدر الكافي الذي يوازي تعدد
اساليب الجريمه طبعا انا قلت لك الجزء
الثاني لا الضحيه ليس مسؤول عنها لان هناك
مشكله في الاجراءات هذا يستغلونها لما
تقولي والله بالنسبه للضحيه المشكله ان ان
المحتالين لديهم سيناريوهات متعدده لابد
ان نكون يعني نعطيهم قدر من الذكاء فهما
يتعاملون اول شيء يقوم برسم السيناريو حسب
المشكله الحاليه يعني على سبيل المثال
الان جمع الاموال والتبرعات المشكله اللي
حاصله في بالنسبه لسوريا وتركيا الان
تستغل لان الان اصبحت الان لديهم سيناريو
مش كورونا اوراق صارت ابعد لانه كما ذكرت
لك هي ترسم على سيناريوهات متعدده على حسب
الحاله على حسب الوضع الاقتصادي على حسب
قوه الدوله على حسب توجه الدوله فانت تتجه
لها رسومات كثيره هذه اصبحت جرائم منظمه
الان تحولت الجريمه الماليه الى جريمه
تقدم كخدمه وهذا الاصعب لارتباطها
بالانترنت فاصبحوا المجرمين المحتارين لا
يستطيع المواطن العادي ان ينتبه لمثل هذه
الامور لان مثل ما قلت لك الان الاحتيالات
يعني على سبيل المثال انا بعطيك احد
الامثله استغلال المشهورين في التواصل
الاجتماعي للاعلان عن هذه المواقع عن هذا
المواقع يعني
كذلك بعض القنوات او بعض
المشهوره او اللي هو المواقع المشهوره
كذلك يعني هذه اول نوعيه هذه المواقع من
دون اننا نسميها يعني طبعا موثوقه مواقع
موثوقه ومعروفه على مستوى المملكه ولها
ثقل طبعا هي او على مستوى الدول العربيه
لها ثقل احنا لما نتكلم عنها لابد ان نعرف
كيفيه تركيبها لماذا هي مواقع للتداول
المالي سنتوقع المالي مثلا الصحف مشهوره
صحف اعلاميه مشهوره في المملكه او في
الدول العربيه نتكلم عنها في الدول
العربيه نعم تنشر لماذا لان كما حنا جهاز
العلمي مجلس الوزراء الداخلي راب جامعه
نايف تقوم بتحليل المشكله اين هي المشكله
كيف يتم الاعلان عنها لانه اساسا الموقع
المعروف او الموثوق في الدول العربيه هو
وقع ضحيه لوكاله الاعلانات الخارجيه هو لا
يعلم قام بتاجير لهم جزء فقاموا باستقلال
وتاجيرا للمحتالين فاصبحت الان هذا لما
نتكلم عن دخول التقنيه اصبحت الان عوائقها
كثيره اسلوب التحدياتها اكثر يعني
التحدياتها اكثر يعني لابد ان الضحيه طبعا
هو في جزء من المشاركه في بعض القضايا
وليس كل القضايا ليس سببا رئيسيا طيب من
الاسباب الموجوده هو الضحيه الجزء اللي
ذكرت انت اساسا الان بعد ما دخلت الان
التقنيه في الجريمه الماليه الان النماذج
الدوليه في مكافحه الجريمه المعلومه
الجريمه الماليه اختلفت تماما على سبيل
المثال سنغافوره انشات مركزا متخصصا عام
2019 بدات الدول الان من 2017 و18 و 19
وتتسابق الزمن لان هذه المساله مساله
الاحتيال المالي عبر الانترنت اصبحت يعني
شائعه وكبيره وكثير من الناس تعرضوا يعني
لخطرها انا اشكرك ما تبقى عندي صراحه كثير
من الوقت
جزء مهم جدا طبعا اعطت اولويه لهذه
الجريمه وقامت هذه الورشه حتى تقوم بمعرفه
الاساليب الاكثر انتشارا الاساليب
الاجراميه وكذلك التعرف على الجديده وكذلك
افضل مراسات وستقوم ايضا
بالخروج بتصور بحيث انها تساهم الورشه
مقسمه لاربع اقسام مهمه انا ما عندي وقت
بس المهم عصف الذهني هذه من احد لهم
المهام وكذلك الجروب ديسكشن او الحالات
النقاش لان هذه مهمه اللي راح تطلع بوظائف
جديده لمكافحه الاحتيال المالي على متجر
التوفيق لكم ان شاء الله شكرا
جزيلا مدير مركز الجرائم السيبرانيه
والادله الرقميه بجامعتين في العربيه
للعلوم الامنيه الدكتور عبد الرزاق
المرجان شكرا الدكتور شكرا لك
اطلقت السعوديه خلال الاشهر الماضيه عدد
من الصناديق الحكوميه والتي تهدف لتعزيز
ودعم تنفيذ برامجها ضمن رؤيه 2030 المزيد
حول تلك الصناديق مع الزميله العنود
العبدلي لنتابع
بهدفي تعزيز المشاريع السياحيه والثقافيه
وتحقيق فرص اقتصاديه تنمويه تماشيا مع
رؤيه 2030 اطلقت السعوديه مؤخرا عددا من
الصناديق التي تهدف الى دعم قطعه اقتصاديه
حيويه اول هذه الصناديق مشاهدينا هو صندوق
التنميه السياحي والذي يعمل على تحقيق
الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للسياحه والهادفه
الى تعزيز سوره السعوديه وجهه سياحيه
رائده عالميا ثلاثه اهداف رئيسيه لصندوق
التنميه السياحي والتي تكمن في دعم تمويل
المشاريع في المناطق الاقل نموا وتعزيز
تنميه الاقتصاديه بالاضافه الى التركيز
على استدامه راس المال الصندوق وفق ما كشف
عنه وزير السياحه احمد الخطيب في يناير
الماضي قام بتمويل 25 مشروعا خلال عام
ونصف بقيمته 15 مليار و لاعطاء صوت جديد
للثقافه السعوديه مشاهدينا وتعزيز هويتها
وحفظ ارثها الحضاري ياتي دور صندوق
التنميه الثقافي الذي يهدف الى تنميه
القطاع الثقافي وتحقيق الاستدامه من خلال
دعم المشاريع الثقافيه وتسهيل الاستثمار
في الانشطه الثقافيه صندوق التنميه
الثقافي مشاهدينا سيركز على دعم 16 قطاعا
ثقافيا من خلال برامج تنمويه باليات تمويل
مختلفه
ولتعزيز مكانه السعوديه مشاهدينا مركزا
عالميا الفعاليات والاحداث المتنوعه
المرتبطه بقطاعات الثقافه والسياحه
والترفيه وكذلك الرياضه الامير محمد بن
سلمان اعلن عن اطلاق صندوق الفعاليات
الاستثماري والذي يهدف الى الاسهام في
الناتج المحلي بثمانيه وعشرين مليار ريال
بحلول العام
45 من خلال تنويع مصادر الدخل غير النف
كما يهدف مشاهدينا هذا الصندوق بشكل اساسي
لتطوير اكثر من 35 موقعا في السعوديه
وزياده فرص الاستثمار المباشره لشركات
والبنوك العالميه وتوفير 160 الف وظيفه
ولاجل تمكين مشاركه القطاع الخاص من
الاستثمار بمشاريع البنيه التحتيه في
السعوديه وتعزيز جاذبيه الفرص الاستثماريه
للمشاريع ياتي دور صندوق البنيه التحتيه
لدعم المشاريع في القطاعات الحيويه كالنقل
والمياه والطاقه والصحه والتعليم
والاتصالات وكذلك البنيه التحتيه الرقميه
وغيرها مما سينعكس ايجابا على تنميه
الاقتصاد الوطني ويعزز من جوده الحياه تصل
مشاهدينا قيمه المبالغ المرصوده في
الصندوق لدعم المشروعات الى 200 مليار
ريال على مدى السنوات العشر المقبله الامر
الذي يسهم في تنميه الناتج المحلي
الاجمالي وتوفير فرص للعمل
اعلنت وزاره داخليه السعوديه في بيان لها
اليوم عن ضبطها نحو 17 الف مخالف لانظمه
الاقامه والعمل وامن الحدود خلال اسبوع
بالاضافه لضبط ما يزيد عن 500 مخالف حاول
الدخول الى البلاد بطرق غير نظاميه
الداخليه السعوديه ذكرت ايضا ان الانظمه
المطبقه على المخالفين نتج عنها ترحيل
اكثر من 12 الف شخص الى خارج السعوديه
خلال اسبوع
الرابعه مستمره وفيها بعد قليل 220 لاعبه
يشاركنا في منافسات بطوله ارامكو السعوديه
النسائيه الدوليه للكولف
حياكم الله من جديد الى مدينه الملك عبد
الله الاقتصاديه برابط غرب السعوديه حيث
تتواصلوا فعاليات منافسات بطوله ارامكو
السعوديه النسائيه الدوليه للجولف والتي
تاتي تحت مظله الجوله الاوروبيه للسيدات
تشهد البطوله مشاركه 120 لاعبه من مختلف
دول العالم فيما يبلغ مجموع جوائز البطوله
خمسه ملايين دولار امريكي هذا وتعد
البطوله ثالث البطولات في روزنامه العام
2023 للجوله الاوروبيه للسيدات واولى
بطولاتها في السعوديه للعام الجاري
من ملعب وانادي رويال جرينز بمدينه الملك
عبد الله الاقتصاديه ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه السلطان السلمي السلطان مساء
الخير مرحبا بك معي ماذا لديك سلطان
اهلا بك واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
اليوم هو اليوم الثالث لبطوله ارامكو
السعوديه للسيدات وتجن في رياضه الجولف
المقدمه من صندوق الاستثمارات السعودي
هنالك منافسات كبيره جدا بين مئه وعشرين
لاعبه يتنافسون بطبيعه الحال على جوائز
هذه البطوله التي تبلغ قيمتها 5 مليون
دولار تم اقصاء قرابه نصف المشاركات تبقى
63 لاعب يتنافسون اليوم من المتوقع غدا ان
تنال البطوله بين اربع لاعبات كانوا قد
حصلوا على بعض الجوائز العالميه وفازوا
بهذه البطوله في النسخ الثلاث الماضيه هذه
النسخه الرابعه يعني حول يعني يتنافسون
ويتدربون الى حتى هذه الساعه نشاهد ان
امامكم بعض اللاعبات يعني يتلقون بعض
التدريبات الاضافيه داخل هذه البطوله
هنالك 18 حفره ببيئات مختلفه يتمرنون
ويلعبون عليها الجولات التي تبدا من
الساعه السابعه صباحا
الساعه الرابعه عصرا هنالك اهتمام كبير
كافه وسائل الاعلام العالميه تتابع هذه
البطوله كافه المهتمين في رياضه الجولف
يلقون اهتمام كبير جدا لهذه البطوله
العالميه التي تبلغ جوائزها قيمه 5 مليار
عفوا خمسه مليون دولار تفاصيل حول ذلك
الاستاذه رزان الحسين هي مسؤوله الفعاليات
هنا في جولف السعوديه بدايه ارسله على
شاشه العربيه ممكن نسال اليوم ايش اللي
يميز هذه النسخه عن بقيه ثلاث نسخ الماضيه
اهلا وسهلا فيكم والله يحييكم هنا في
النسخه الرابعه من بطوله ارامكو السعوديه
الدوليه للسيدات بنسختها الرابعه شرفتونا
ونورتونا
البطوله هذه مميزه بحاجتين عندنا رفعنا
الجائزه
لتصبح مساويه للسعوديه الدوليه للرجال
وهذا اول مره يصير في تاريخ الجولف احنا
قاعدين نصنع تاريخ كبير في هذه الرياضه
وبرضو عندنا
لمشاركات السعوديات في يوم المحترفين
والهوى كان له تاثير كبير ايجابي لنا
وجودهم ومشاركتهم مع اللاعبات المحترفات
هذا ممكن يقول لي السؤال المهم اليوم 120
لعبه السعوديه متى ممكن نشوف سعوديات يعني
يحترفون رياضه الجول
الاحترافيه في الجولف يتطلب لها وقت ولكن
انت تبدا كهاوي في هذه اللعبه طبعا هناك
في مبادرات كثيره من جولف السعوديه على
مدار السنه للرجال وللسيدات وللعوائل
لتفعيل هذه الرياضه ومشاركتهم
وتشجيعهم على على هذه الرياضه وزي ما تشوف
الحمد لله قبل اربع سنوات عشرين عشرين
اطلقنا مبادره السيدات اولا واليوم نشوف
هذول السيدات السعوديات المشاركين مع
لاعبات عالميات محترفات هذا يحفزهم حتى
انهم يكملون في هذا المجال ان شاء الله
ونشوفهم محترفات
شكرا الك انا معنا رزان الحسين وهي مسؤوله
الفعاليات هنا في جولف السعوديه يعني
جماهير كبيره تحضر لهذه البطوله هنا في
مدينه الملك عبد الله الاقتصاديه في نادي
الجولف من شتى بقع العالم هنالك مهتمين
ومحبين رياضه الجولف هذا رياضه يعني وهذه
البطوله تحظى بمتابعه ومشاهده كبيره جدا
لهذه البطوله غدا 4 متسابقات يتنافسون
للفوز بالجائزه نتحدث عن اللاعبه
الامريكيه وايضا نتحدث عن نيوزلنديه ريال
وغيرهم من المتسابقات العالميات يتنافسون
غدا لنيل هذه البطوله تم اقصاء 63 لاعبه
تبقى هؤلاء اربعه غدا سوف يتنافسون على
هذه البطوله نتحدث انه تم تهيئه الملاعب
بشكل كبير جدا قبل بدا هذه البطوله لتكون
بيئه رياضيه مناسبه للاعب رياضه الجولف
نعم اشكرك جزيل الشكر من ملعب ونادي رويال
جرينز بمدينه الملك عبد الله الاقتصاديه
راس العربي سلطان السلمي
كشف تقرير صادر عن مختبرات الغذاء بامانه
العاصمه المقدسه عن الاطعمه الاكثر تلوثا
خلال عام 2022 وذلك من خلال فحص اكثر من
26 الف عينه من خلال مقتبلات الامانه
نتابع
عبر تقنيات حديثه في مجال فحص الاغذيه
يقوم مختبر السلامه الغذائيه بامانه مكه
بدور حيوي وهام في الحفاظ على الصحه
العامه للمستهلكين من الاطعمه والمياه
الملوثه في عدد من المطاعم ومحل المياه
حيث تم ضبط اكثر من 26 الف عينه خلال عام
واحد وفحصها في المختبر الخاص بالاغذيه
لتكشف عن نسبه تلوث متفاوته في هذه
الاطعمه اضفنا مختبرات متنقله تم تجربتها
خلال العام الماضي في المشاعر المقدسه
خلال العام الحالي سوف نزيد من العربات
المتنقله لتحليل اكبر قدر من العينات
المقدمه لحجاج بيت الله الحرام
وفي التقليل السنوي لاعمال مختبر السلامه
الغذائيه بامانه مكه بلغ حجم العينات التي
تم تحليلها ضمن نظام الرقابه الصحيه وبلغت
26,421 عينت غذاء ومياه خلال عام 2020
فيما بلغ نسبه صالح منها
1.97 مقابل
2.9% غير صالحه للاستهلاك الادمي ولو
نظرنا وقارنا بما تم تحليله خلال العام
المنصرم 2022
لوجدنا انه النسبه كانت في التحسن بنسبه
تزيد عن 3% خلال العام الحالي باذن الله
تعالى راح تزيد الجولات راح يكون في اعداد
عينات اكبر
استعدادا لموسم الحج بطاقه الاستيعابيه
الكامله
واستخدم المختبر احدث التقنيات لتعزيز
الامن الغذائي المستدام بهدف زياده وعي
المستهلك بمخاطر الاغذيه الملوثه مع ضروره
الاهتمام بمصادر الاطعمه والتاكد من انها
من مصادر موثوقه يقوم على تشغيل المختبرات
كادر سعودي مؤهل تم تزويده بالعديد من
الدورات التدريبيه والتاهيليه داخل
المملكه وخارجها جميع المختبرات مهيئه
ومجهزه باحدث التجهيزات لعمل الفحوصات
اللازمه ويمثل مختبر السلامه الغذائيه
بامانه مكه للمستهلكين خط الدفاع الاول
للوقايه من الامراض والمخاطر الصحيه
المتعلقه بسلامه الغذاء عبر سلسله طويله
ومعقده من المراحل حتى يصل في النهايه الى
المستهلك بالمنطقه محمد الزهراني العربيه
مكه
الرابع بابرز عناوينها
بعد نحو اسبوعين من الزلزال انتشار ثلاثه
ناجحه من تحت انقاضها طي ووفاه احدهم
لاحقا
البحث والانقاذ السعودي يواصل عملياته في
46 موقعا بثلاث مدن تركيه
امين يحب النيتو يقول بانه من الواجب
توسيع العضويه في حلف الناتو لتعزيز الامن
في اوروبا
تقرير للانتربول يكشف بان جرائم الاحتيال
المالي تشكل تهديدا خطيرا لدول الشرق
الاوسط
شكرا لك المتابعه نهايه الرابعه الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]